there is something serious about this
podcast I did the other day if you've
not sat down and and seriously looked at
my content a little while or if you're
somebody super deep into my content an
incredible job here in this podcast
going in a little bit of a different
direction about me and my mindset I'm
funny feeling when I read the comments
that this will be really really talked
about and really analyzed I hope you
enjoy it
I'm very excited about it sit down grab
a cup of eggnog and enjoy a lot of
people try to D train attention through
social media and making a business of it
so what can be better than to talk to an
expert on the subject welcome to this
podcast Gary Vaynerchuk how are you I'm
amazing how are you I'm fine good thanks
for having me listen how does one become
an expert on a thing that is still
growing and people still try to figure
it out I mean social media by being a
practitioner you know there was a day
when painting was new and the people
that became good at it were the ones
that were painting it's amazing to me
how many people have opinions about
Facebook or Instagram or LinkedIn or
making videos or doing this kind of
podcast and getting people to listen to
it a whole lot of people with opinions
who've never done it and so I believe
the great way to be great at anything is
to be a practitioner you know it's kind
of people ask me all the time I make the
analogy you know you can read about
push-ups but if you want the results
that push-ups give you you have to do
the push-ups and I just think a lot of
people with business entrepreneurship
and specifically being a social media
content creator or a modern media
digital creator read a lot talk a lot to
pontificate a lot and don't do a lot the
way I figured out how to have my podcast
the way I figured out my YouTube show
the way I figured out everything I do is
by doing and you're gonna get some bumps
and you're gonna make some mistakes I
think most people don't do because
they're worried about what other people
think
what kind of generation are we talking
about everybody you know I think
everybody I think I don't think this is
as generational as people think I think
this is more psychology than it is you
know none of the four people sitting in
this room right well the baboon's
younger but the three of it and you're
pretty held real good yeah talking to
our sound engineer that's right
I bring everybody into these podcasts I
like to break the walls and visualize
for you everybody who's listening look
the three of us didn't like 35 okay look
you know it's not about how old you I'm
42 and I feel more curious and more
understanding of the culture in the game
than plenty of people that are 18 I
think it's a mindset and so it's a very
interesting time to be alive there's so
much opportunity and I'm excited to be a
part of it but you are a very how do you
say special thing is that you have this
psychological skill that a lot of people
come to you with a lot of problems and
they try to get advices from you and you
just give them advices how what kind of
skill is - yeah that's psychiatrist
that's you know psychologist that's
right you know if I was a if I was the
son of me instead of me I would have
probably went to a top-five university
and been a big-time psychiatrist or
psychologist like a hundred percent
because I was born an immigrant in a
different environment and probably had a
little bit too much you know competitive
entrepreneurial DNA but yeah I think
it's interesting as my life evolves that
some of my natural skills are becoming
more clear and it's less about being a
Salesman for being good at digital
marketing I'm very comfortable giving
advice because I think I'm under
educated and I keep things very simple
like human behavior comes very natural
to me which is why I've been very good
at predicting what people are gonna do
next
it's also the same skill that allows me
to know that most of people's issues
come from their parents or the
environment they were born in
most things are very simple we don't
want to look them in the face
you know Facebook's not changing us
Facebook's not making us bad people
Facebook's exposing that we were bad to
begin with you know like these are funny
things to me they're historical I'm a
big fan of history it was one class I
was actually decent at and I think
that's another thing that's worked well
for me
this is just rinse and repeat you know
what's happening right now on Facebook
and Twitter is the same reason that
governments when they want to be
dictatorships control the media because
the media controls the mindset and so
you know I uh I think my skill is human
behavior and I think my vice or my
intrigued on another part of my life is
building businesses and and I think
that's what me you know I bought Bitcoin
in 2014 not because I guessed not
because of anything else but because I
could see what was gonna happen in 17
and 18 and yeah I think you know I make
the joke earlier about special but I do
feel special and I don't say that with
ego I say that as a compliment to my
parents and to my circumstance and to
America and to the Soviet Union for that
matter the circumstances of who I became
are far more the factor than me but I do
see around corners and not because I'm
Nostradamus but because I deeply am
consumer centric i watch what people
wear when haircuts change I'm fascinated
by that you know when fashion I be been
great in fashion I would have been if I
had that gene like my daughter is very
creative and I can see she has a lot of
me in her I can see her being a big-time
fashion player in the future because if
she deploys her creativity to fashion
and she can see around corners she'll be
an innovator of style and so yeah things
are very simple to me but social media
and
and the the human brain goes
hand-in-hand I mean the human ecology
and human brain goes hand-in-hand with
everything social media is very
important because it's communication you
and I right now are sitting in some room
at some conference this amazingly
handsome talented sound engineer has a
very small device doesn't look so
complicated to me I wouldn't know what
to do with it but it's not big hears and
I know that this whole enterprise here
is not costing a whole lot to create and
not costing a whole lot to distribute if
you guys know what you're doing and I
doesn't cost me a lot to distribute on
my podcast which is a top 50 podcast in
the world that whole enterprise used to
cost millions of dollars in studio costs
in distribution it's we're living in the
internet age why don't people get this
more and foster I mean because people
look backwards instead of looking
forward 90% of people default into
looking behind them instead of looking
ahead of them it's the human psyche I
think most people are scared of change
and they look for negatives there's
people that are trying to blame suicide
rates on social media it's laughable the
issue with suicide rates in the world is
bad parenting and and many other
variables and maybe social media but -
by narrowly blame a media is silly and
so I think when I look at what happens
so I think there's a lot of Technology
fear-mongering one thing I like to say a
lot is that we put writing a letter on a
pedestal but kids that are texting are
bad I think that's crazy the message is
important not the thing that delivers it
you invested as you said before you knew
about Facebook before Facebook Facebook
was big and invested in facebook twitter
tumblr tumblr uber
and you are a rich son of a gun yeah
yeah but how can you inspire your kids I
mean you had a total different I can't I
can't inspire in the way that I was
inspired you know when I would stay at
too much a hundred percent and they have
other things they have a father who's
gonna end up being famous and that might
be good or bad
first the way I'm gonna inspire my kids
is to first do what I always do which is
audit who they are not who I hope they
are I first have to deploy
self-awareness and empathy and and
understand who they are so for my
daughter who's eight I'm starting to get
a understanding and then three or four
or five years I think I'm gonna have a
very good understanding I'm gonna
inspire my two children and what I try
to inspire everybody who's listening to
this is I don't want them to become me I
only want one thing for people that I
have really outside of health the only
thing I wish for people is them to love
what they do as much as I do when I do
new podcasts or new video shows I love
reading the comments of the audience
that don't know me inevitably 5% of the
audience will leave a comment that
refers to drugs if they want to be
really snarky they'll say I you know
cocaine ritalin you know they they think
that I'm on something and I always reply
because I've never tried smoking a
cigarette let alone done adderall I
reply with grat the aunt so they'll say
cocaine and I'll reply gratitude I'm so
grateful that I do what I love everyday
and what I love for clarification is
just being an entrepreneur playing the
challenges
the risk the excitement but you're also
high on your own energy you have
tremendous energy I have tremendous
energy because it builds momentum when
you're doing what you want to be doing
for a long period of time it builds
momentum I didn't have the same energy
in school I hated school I was
optimistic
I was high-energy that's my DNA but not
like this this is now a supernova
because now I'm 20 years into
in my zone the the breath of fresh air
the exhale I had on the first day that I
worked at my dad's liquor store like
worked like there was no more school
ever again
that was incredible that is a I will
never replicate that feeling again I
miss that feeling it's funny I've never
talked about this out loud that would
have been the best day of my life in a
lot of ways knowing that I was embarking
on the thing that I was meant to do so
if my children want to give away all my
money want to paint in the Himalayas
want to start a school want to or want
to climb the mountain and be bigger than
me I just want to inspire them to be
themselves and support them mentally but
shouldn't q that didn't like the school
system at all shouldn't you be the one
to start the school mm-hmm
I sure shed and and I will call me you
got it and and by the way I think I am
and this is and I've always dreamed of
starting a school because I wanted to
[ __ ] stick it back to them so that we
could build a school for people like me
what's interesting is I'm realizing I'm
doing it now I have an enormous amount
of 10 to 15 year olds following me
across YouTube and Instagram and I'm
teaching that boy you know maybe I'm not
teaching them the way that people think
teaching is done but I am teaching them
and I see it and oh I have a great story
I was flying yesterday from Gothenburg
to Stockholm and I sat with a man whose
18 year old son is obsessed with me
he lives in New Jersey of all places
small world and he said that I made of
so he's telling me he's you know he's
telling me everything and I'm very
flattered and he's a young man that his
father he's 44 I'm 42 but he has an 18
year old son and he says my son you know
I was a good student the father saying
my son wasn't as good but he wants to be
an entrepreneur and he every day he
lives at home still and every day I walk
to work come home anytime I'm going by
him when he's out and not in his room
and working on the kitchen or living
room I hear your voice and then he
turned to me very emotionally and he
said thank you and it
it's kind of making me a little bit
emotional right now he said my son is
such a better man now because of you and
he's and then he started telling me
reasons accountability
you know I'm teaching real stuff not
memorizing who the fourth president was
and and then he talked about me talking
about my father and he says that his son
is very competitive with him and I was
very competitive my father but I put out
some content about how I think about my
dad even though we're different even
there's a lot of don't agree with and he
said to me that his relationship with
his son has fundamentally changed since
then
what do you say what do you say to this
youngsters that make such an impact to
those who are listening and maybe
haven't know yet I tell the truth I tell
them the truth
their parents are telling them the truth
their school isn't telling them the
truth I tell them the truth I tell them
a lot of things they'd like to hear like
[ __ ] the system forget about what your
parents want for you this is your life
do not live with regret and then I tell
them other truths they don't like which
is your [ __ ] entitled you haven't
proven [ __ ] stop being full of [ __ ] like
life is long be kind nobody gives a [ __ ]
if you have a Mercedes or a Rolex shut
the [ __ ] up
get to work I tell them the truth okay
you're right anyway and you know what
let's hold on to that second for a
second because it could be very valuable
for your listeners I'm fascinated by
what you just did to what I just said
and how that plays out in my entire life
when I go to can for the marketing
festival and I go onstage and I talk and
I talk about stuff nobody agrees with me
in the industry but then at two o'clock
in the morning they'll say to me after a
couple of cocktails you're right when
parents hear my stuff and they're and
they're smart and they're and they're
smart they don't like a lot of what I
say but they'll tell me you're right you
just did it what I'm trying to figure
out is what makes one do something that
they know isn't right
when they know what's right what is
creating that behavior
what I think is happening is they're
worried about what other people think I
have a lot of empathy for a 49 year old
woman raising two teenagers in a
neighborhood where she has a lot of
friends where she believes in something
but she doesn't do it because she
doesn't want the scrutiny from the other
moms I understand I just don't know why
she's choosing herself over her children
I think about that stuff I don't want my
kids to be entrepreneurs too many people
think of their children as property and
as indicators of who they are and I
understand that I get so proud when my
kids do things I get it I just don't
think it's in the best interest of the
kids and so I'm trying to have
conversations that a lot of people
aren't it I just said that for the last
three minutes because I hope somebody on
my blog or somebody in your podcast one
if one parent one if one parent just got
inspired in the last five minutes those
kids lives are much better for
everything you know what of it you know
how incredible that is that's what media
is that's the world we live in today I
would have never been known but the
thing you say get your [ __ ] together yes
I recognize that I'm a daughter of
immigrants as well so we hear that a lot
and I'm saying that immigrants are the
best people on earth because we create a
lot of good teenagers but there is
something when you have a new person you
have to fight it to fight my kids can't
be as hungry as me I think the challenge
that you and I have as you know kids of
immigrants and I'm an immigrant myself
some real close to it is
I'm ideological about the immigrant
framework I'm with you like even like we
know how lucky we are
we're like because we're hungry or we
were we know what [ __ ] you know it's
good it's better entitlement and
prosperity has flaws on the back end but
I think the mistake a lot of people make
is they try to fabricate the reality of
the situation I see a lot of my rich
friends send their kids to Africa for
two days and think it's gonna change
them
I think what's better is my
recommendation for anybody who's
listening who thinks that their kids are
in a situation that is spoiled or
entitled or fruitful you know my big
thing is I can't fake environment my
kids live on the Upper East Side in
Manhattan go to private schools have
friends who have private planes I myself
you know my daughter and son go with me
the other day to buy I want to go buy
jeans and buy them some candy
I took 11 selfies right I could choose
to be rude to people and say I'm with my
family but that's not in me so I chose
to do that but that's affecting my
children you know my daughter's like
you're famous you're a legend and you
know I can't fake their life but there
is something I think that you where
you're going that I think is super
important I do think some things are
non-negotiable so my rig my kids are
gonna be rich and they're gonna be
spoiled they're not gonna be as hungry
as me when I was 12 I asked my mom to
buy Nintendo she said go buy it I
figured it out I could do that to my
kids but there's too much surrounding
the framework of our family that that's
not where I'm gonna go but where I am
gonna go is the following so for example
something that is very politically
incorrect is to hit your children right
not a big thing that we do anymore I'm
very comfortable saying on the record I
will hit my child if they ever ever use
my and my wife's wealth to be rude to
another child if my kids ever once in
their life make another kid feel bad cuz
me and Lizzy are rich and they're using
that to make somebody else feel bad I
will punch them in the face I hope they
hear that yo kids you know what's even
better it's better than hearing it
whether they listen to this podcast or
the clip and if they use it if they ever
hear it it's gonna matter a lot less
than the fact that it is our religion
inside our home they they've heard it
it's been heard they don't even know it
yet but it's established and I think you
know kindness and being kind is
non-negotiable I don't need them to be
as hungry as I am cuz they're not going
to be I need them to be kind and I need
them to figure out who they are and then
I need them to go all in
if they are equally if they make
paintings out of asparagus and make
eight dollars a year I will be very
proud as long as they have as much fire
in their eye the way I do about my thing
my fire turned into wealth I get it but
there's a lot of people who have fire
who do much greater things than create
wealth I will tell you I have much more
fire to inspire people and make them win
than my own my personal wealth once I
made a hundred thousand dollars a year I
thought I was rich that was big I was
pumped I'm still pumped a hundred
thousand I can live very good right now
this house is big yes I agree and and
and so I don't like stuff like I don't
need money for anything
I don't I so if my kids become you know
lecturers you know but only make seventy
three thousand a year there they're
gonna make me very proud as long as
they're fired or not been happy let's
continue talk about young people but
also business-wise okay there are a lot
of examples of brands that are panicking
believing that they are facing their
final days they buy consultants to
analyze the social media and they still
fail to reach out to Millennia's
Millennials for example and I think just
to take an example I think only one of
five Millennials has tried to Bing back
from the tunnels yeah Big Mac yeah yes
and I mean it doesn't matter how much
social media they try to expose
themselves in it doesn't work so then
McDonald's started - well it doesn't
this work so why what do you say well
let's start with this if Boehner media
did the marketing for McDonald's and
they gave me carte blanche five out of
five Millennials would try the Big Mac
I'm not joking and I think I can get
every [ __ ] person in America
including vegan moms to eat a [ __ ]
Big Mac I don't think that you know I
don't think big McDonald's big problem
is the food trends because they sell
plenty of salads and they've got all
sorts of reasons I think it's the
marketing I really do
Donald's spends 80 percent of its money
ninety percent of its money on
traditional or traditional digital their
mailing in their modern contemporary
culturally relevant content in the seven
places that Millennials play their
mailing it in
they spent but this is a point yes but
some other economists say that
Millennials don't buy it don't trust
anyone everyone won't meanwhile
meanwhile Millennials are wearing adidas
and vans and champion hoodies
Millennials buy plenty under buying
smart water like Millennials are [ __ ]
people I can trick a millennial to do
anything I want how's your doctor trick
them by making things that are valuable
to them you know how I trick them by
giving them what they want by not giving
them what I want
by being consumer centric by listening
to Millennials Millennials will tell you
what they want you're just not listening
you know why because older generations
have too much audacity I can get a
millennial to do anything I want because
I'm deploying humility and I'm listening
that's why social media yes also borders
yes and you live in the u.s. how can you
use this fact of two cultures this is
wise I mean we have to leave out you
know if I if I you know if I want to be
a big personal brand in Moscow I have
more autonomy to do that that I do in
New Delhi or in San Paulo so one I think
everybody's truth is very important you
know one of the reasons I think I do
very well in urban and hip-hop worlds is
because I liked it as a kid because I
spent a lot of time with a lot of
minorities because 90% of the kids in my
college or minority and so I think that
what's amazing is if you're willing to
embrace your truth there's an enormous
amount of strength in that
so for example there's a lot of people
listening right now with diseases that
they will never tell
anybody usually mental right I'm very
fascinated by what's happening with you
know meditation mental illness you know
if you're bipolar twelve years ago
you're hiding it I think you need to
expose it and so I think borders are not
just you know our ancestors and where
we're born but I think it's what you
know what makes us I mean you know I
think that there's so much more that we
should be talking about and taking
control of it I very early on talked
about being a bad student when it wasn't
that popular I cursed on content in the
early and mid 2000s when that was not
popular but it was my truth I curse I'm
a bad student and there's something very
powerful about truths so when I think
about crossing borders if it's your
truth you can be unbelievably successful
I also think of just as very tactical I
think it's an incredible time to get
bigger in other places if you're willing
to transcribe your content
I'm transcribing my content into
different languages and watching my
popularity grow in Italy and Asia and in
spanish-speaking countries it's very
fascinating to see Facebook is such an
incredible tool yeah I mean I think of I
think of the world is one world I do
think that Soviet succeed in that so I
think Russia and I do think China have
some different variables because of
their structure China's a big mark in
itself it's got its own insular culture
I think Russia it does the same but
other than that I think of the world is
a 1 and Facebook helps us with that 100%
how much time does consume spent time
with Facebook no I don't know what the
updated figure is but here's what I can
tell you almost 50% of time over 50% of
times spent on a mobile device in the
world is being spent on a social network
and Facebook has a disproportionate
amount of that time so just ungodly
hours an hour when you take it I mean
look in today as we record this if you
add up the attention time that is spent
in Facebook and Instagram combined it's
extraordinary the power of that to
how much power does what costs have a
lot I think audio is the next frontier
because it's passive consumption and
time is very important so I'm very
bullish on podcasts I'm very bullish on
Alexa and Google home and you know
devices that interact with youth and
voice I'm betting the farm on voice
being the next frontier
well who's inspiring you that's it this
is in question I am I'm not sure so let
me answer this honestly that's a good
you know I'm inspired by everybody and
nobody if you want to be honest right
I'm I've never I've never been framed up
as somebody who looked up or admired
people you know outside of my parents
and really even in silos like my mom is
a parent er and as a human being she
gives advice everybody to just in a much
smaller circle than I did so I grew up
watching that or to your earlier
question and my mom said very much my
hero my dad from the work ethic you know
the hustle thing that I talk about but
it's interesting I I'm my wife for her
inability to complain there's a lot of
people and then and then and then you
know just silly stuff like let's use Bab
and he's in the room watching Tyler work
for me for a year knowing from day one
he came to work for a year use my name
and then go out and do his own thing I
knew it I knew it and didn't to watch
him be able to recognize the situation
and realize it was valuable for him to
stay I'm inspired by that now maybe
that's me humble bragging and being look
how good I am
that's fine the millions of emails DMS
and messages I get I mean listen I get
an email and a DM on Instagram every day
that is from somebody that's homeless
10 times a day 20 times a day from a
single mother in a really shitty
situation 30 times a day 30 times a day
from somebody in a mental negative state
do you answer well no I wish [ __ ] man
that France frustrated to have so many
cries for help
yeah no because I'm practical I'm driven
and inspired to be a good man because I
think people are counting on me to be
and I like the challenge I like the
pressure I like it's what I'm
comfortable with
it's Who I am you know Gary you should
listen to my podcast okay I will thank
you for coming thanks for having me on
this episode this podcast I did what was
the most interesting insight you hadn't
heard before in this episode
[Applause]
[Music]